et je poursuis avec Jean Dubé il est
professeur en aménagement du territoire
et de développement régional à
l'Université Laval est aussi co-auteur
d'un ouvrage sur le transport à Québec
bonsoir Monsieur Dubé
bonsoir alors d'abord on n'en connaît
pas évidemment les détails mais quel est
votre réaction à cette nouvelle mouture
du troisième lien donc sans voiture
en fait le premier réaction c'est je
vais être obligé de me référer un peu à
ce qu'on avait écrit quand on a fait le
bouquin en 2021 c'est-à-dire que on
disait dans le livre en fait que si la
CAQ voulait s'obstiner à développer un
troisième lien la seule option qui nous
semblait viable était celle qui était
axée uniquement sur du transport
collectif parce que ajouter des voies
routières ça ne réglerait pas les
problèmes de congestion c'est ça
une chose sur laquelle la science est
plutôt uneanime c'est que on n'a jamais
réglé les problèmes de congestion en
ajoutant des autoroutes mais quand vous
parlez de d'une seule voix pour du
transport collectif est-ce que est-ce
que la demande justement pour ce
transport collectif est-ce qu'elle est
là
il faut peut-être voir le projet aussi
disons sur un angle de long terme et
voir un peu qu'est-ce que ce projet-là
si seulement structuré transport en
commun qu'est-ce qui peut apporter et
pour dans la région de Québec on a une
part modale du transport collectif qui
est vraiment faible et peut-être que
l'idée derrière cette proposition là
c'est de servir de ce projet comme
électrochoc pour essayer de stimuler
l'utilisation des transports collectifs
et d'augmenter la part modale dans la
région urbaine de Québec mais à qui ça
s'adresse vraiment on peut penser que ce
sont les gens qui travaillent dans le
Vieux Québec par exemple ou bien sur la
colline parlementaire c'est ça
ça peut être eux ça peut être des
étudiants aussi qui traversent sur les
deux rives maintenant une institution
Lucar qui est sur la Rive-Sud et on a
l'Université Laval sur la Rive-Nord donc
il y a beaucoup d'étudiants qui risquent
de se déplacer et bon il y a des
étudiants qui se déplacent en voiture
habituellement il y a un lien entre
l'utilisation du transport collectif et
le revenu
ça peut être ces gens-là ça peut être
effectivement ceux qui travaillent par
exemple à des vies il y a
le Desjardins qui est un très grand
employeur de l'autre côté sur la rive
nord en fait vous allez avoir aussi la
fonction publique bon qui peut-être un
peu moins d'utilisation depuis l'arrivée
du télétravail mais malgré tout il y a
aussi des entreprises privées qui sont
dans le centre-ville autant en basse
ville à québecue qu'ailleurs
et effectivement probablement que les
travailleurs seraient serait possible
assez intéressant pour essayer de les
faire basculer parce que si on opte avec
cette option de transport collectif
centre-ville à centre-ville ben là pour
la première fois de l'histoire
pratiquement Québec on a un transport
collectif qui va concurrencer la voiture
et qui va même être meilleur que la
voiture chose qu'on a pratiquement pas
vu et qu'on a et qu'on n'a pas
actuellement à Québec parce qu'il y a
une culture beaucoup de tout à l'auto
non à Québec
on est on est très porté sur la voiture
effectivement mais ce comportement là
s'explique c'est-à-dire que il y a été
pendant un certain nombre d'années où au
Québec était la ville qui avait le plus
de kilomètres d'autoroute par habitant
et donc c'est sûr qu'à ce moment-là le
premier réflexe devient assez facile si
je vais prendre la voiture parce que la
voiture va plus vite que le transport en
commun plus vite que le transport actif
et donc à ce moment-là on se retrouve
toujours avec une espèce de fuite en
avant c'est-à-dire on se dit faut pas
investir dans le transport collectif
parce que la voiture va plus vite mais
si on fait ça ben nécessairement on pose
tout le monde à utiliser la voiture
parce qu'il y a un avantage à le faire
donc peut-être effectivement qu'un des
débuts de cette opération là c'est
d'inculquer une espèce d'électrochoc
est-ce que ça va fonctionner ça il y a
juste le futur qui va nous dire il y a
certains experts qui disent qu'avec deux
ponts vieillissants c'est peut-être pas
très sage de n'avoir qu'une seule voix
pour le transport collectif que tant
qu'à creuser un tunnel si c'est bien ça
qu'on fait il vaudrait peut-être mieux
mettre une voix donc pour pour du
transport routier
encore une fois moi je pense que si on
met du transport routier on va un peu
quand on voit un peu éliminer cet
avantage là qu'on aurait pu donner au
transport collectif si on le dédie
uniquement au transport collectif si on
a un problème effectivement avec les
deux pages je pense que il faut y
réfléchir je pense à Montréal par
exemple qui a remplacé le pont Champlain
on n'a pas eu besoin de creuser un
tunnel pour pas pour remplacer le bon
champion donc si effectivement on a un
problème avec les ponts ben
effectivement remplaçons lait et je
pense que l'option la plus rapide pour
le faire ben c'est de faire un autre
pont à côté de ceux qui est là qui sont
là mais ceci dit je suis pas ingénieur
je peux pas m'avancer trop loin dans les
coups qui peuvent être liés à ces
différents projets là mais la logique
voudrait quand même que si les ponts
sont vieillissants et en fin de vie
peut-être que ce serait une bonne idée
de de remplacer tout comme on a fait à
Montréal avec le pont Champlain mais
pour revenir à ce toit cette nouvelle
mouture du troisième lien selon vous
après tout ce qui a été présenté ça
reste une la meilleure option pour le
moment c'est ça
merci bonne soirée